welcome to this video to key to pee I
don't know or 44 is my score against
this player so let's keep it like that
the Trump offski yeah not a regular
opening of mind but why not for play
that for some variety okay I'm preparing
a 45 year this is a good recipe again
said early g5 so here we go and wow I
didn't expect him to play like that so
I'm out for 94 94 96 hmm okay I can also
play f5 here is that mmm a couple of
interesting options taking on d6 and
then d 5 is also quite interesting
Wow okay that is indeed interesting I'll
do this however I mean he was evil
cancel all right and isn't that kind of
risky when he has to I mean where is he
cannot cast and short anymore so um I
was thinking that this is not playable
at all it ok not be a time sorry yeah
man i piayed of course he can just go
back it looks bad but Knight a5 9 p-3
wasn't was what i was thinking that it
wasn't playable at all so um what he M
ok if I do here how is he defending
their porn with a six
actually funny basics I can actually
take that Bishop takes a seven and I get
a new queen but this is just yeah and
it's just fancy chess with no big point
but rookie one is actually interesting
now I'm actually threatening maybe to
take on on a six or queen a five is also
interesting threatening to take on it
this is a very difficult position from
like he's got no count to play and I'm
already very much in his king queen a5
is an interesting move next if he goes
b6 let's do that between 85 and tending
now to take on a six if he goes b6 no he
doesn't I I can able to fur taken ok so
now I can just capture your right for
simple chess
let's get no counter play here so Queen
chicks or who shakes I guess route
cheeks so that i can double rooks
quickly yeah not move that he's happy
with but what is there what else is
there 9 p-6 I don't know maybe here 94
is the move that that comes next on 84
lat Seaforths more powerful
yeah I'll just double on the B file and
go on etsy 494 this this moves are very
good to the light on you too it's not
needed in this in this whole procedure
okay i think i'll go back here the
question is where i was thinking a three
originally but you might have bishop f8
it's a bit of a bit of an annoyance came
if he takes that c4 is killing that's
not be six now Hilary Knight b6 is
coming check no no that's not going to
help I don't believe it so b5
Queen a8 I guess
yeah I should have should have actually
calculated this a little bit more
precisely it's actually completely
unnecessarily tricky now look f7 he
might be able to i wanted to or we have
seven but he might be able to just sec
the Queen down this is what I didn't
that didn't pay any attention Teague on
v3 now that's a big big hole in my whole
calculation and there's another hole
Queen f7 I wanted to take on be aid but
that bloody bishop on h2 is actually
protecting it oops okay so i made many
mistakes here from that completely
winning position oh I'm a piece down hmm
wow that's what you get for thinking
that every move wins and it wasn't every
move wow that's amazing screwing this
position up it was so utterly winning
okay it seems that he wants to double on
the F foul that's a that's a good idea
ah my god and I cannot even arrest him
there with my queen s that oh my god
okay come on yeah I like I said that was
a terrible game I didn't pay any
attention because that was so
ridiculously lost for like but they
absolutely absolutely thought I can play
everything yeah that was just terrible
so yeah here night c4 is already plus 9
yeah of course I mean it's it's just
it's just a complete wreck of a position
check something like this night tgif
everything winds here besides the stuff
that
just not what I did okay that should
still win I I don't believe that I can't
hold this kind of position but I wasn't
I wasn't really paying any attention
that was just bad I'm just bad you know
that's not working I didn't even see be
five so and here I was thinking what we
have seven but you can just take this
yeah this is this is winning as well it
can just take this because this is
protected now that was a clear case of
of having yeah I basically saw saw
thought the game is one already and
didn't didn't pay any attention anymore
it was just so bad for black gym well it
wasn't ok I am glad that they played
that totally okay not see highs of
course I should have thought about this
a little bit I mean this was already
this when I thought everything every
move wins so let's he was coming anyway
and even here 94 this wind even with
Queens off how is he defending this this
is also deadly yeah there are many ways
to to win this just not what i did i was
just not paying any attention this is
already a little bit tricky not quite
clear if this is good anymore
nanites affords always getting into b5
this was my original intention here and
this is also better attending attending
this night see for him yeah there also
was winning so I should have just done
what I originally it was planning I
guess okay well the moral of the story
is don't think you have won the game
until your opponent resigns or as
checkmated thanks for watching